dans la majestueuse cathédrale du christ
sauveur
c'est moscovite célèbrent pâques en
grande pompe en présence de vladimir
poutine le patriarche kirill est un
allié du président russe en ce week-end
pascal il a appelé à la fin de la guerre
en ukraine mais sans la condamner pour
autant que chacun d'entre vous de sa
bougie reçoivent le feu du saint
sépulcre à kiev ces seuls dans l'église
sainte sophie que le président ukrainien
s'est lui adressé à son peuple alors
qu'aucune trêve pascale n'a été accordée
par la russie sur grosne ipaq nous donne
l'espoir que la lumière l'encore sur les
ténèbres
que le bien l'emportent sur le mal
que la ville en porte sur la mort julien
et que l'ukraine soit victorieuse pas
l'amour
malgré les bombardements de nombreux
ukrainiens ont bravé leur peur pour
célébrer pâques ici à ta peau ridja dans
l'est de l'ukraine ses fidèles
orthodoxes sont venus recevoir la
bénédiction pascale mais la plupart ne
s'attarde pas
nous ne sommes même pas entré dans
l'église on a tout fait très vite nous
nous sommes fait bénir par le prêtre et
maintenant nous rentrons chez nous pour
retrouver notre famille et nos voisins
cette année tout va très vite
les autorités ont demandé aux ukrainiens
de suivre les célébrations de pâques sur
internet et de ne surtout pas enfreindre
le couvre-feu s'il participé à des
rassemblements